bonjour avoue gérard vespière merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france
comment vous expliquez la capacité de
benyamin nétanyahou a formé un
gouvernement malgré ses alliances avec
la droite radicale et les partis
sionistes bien il faut tout simplement
revenir aux résultats d'élections à les
résultats de l'élection donc du mois de
mars ont donné au likoud son plus
mauvais score
il est sorti donc du mandat précédent
avec 36 sièges et lors des élections
donc dernière en mars il n'a recueilli
que 30 sièges à voyez vous donc comme
ils vous avez une
un objectif de majorité à 61 sièges
et bien même en cas d'alliance avec des
parties complémentaires le likoud
n'auraient pas eu la majorité de sa
propre majorité donc on est dans une
situation a vraiment nouvelle et en
revenant à nouveau aux résultats des
élections du mois de mars est bien le
likoud a perdu 200 mille voix qui est
liée à sa perte de sièges bien sûr donc
voyez vous le likoud était vraiment dans
une phase ascendante
lle descendante pardon une phase
descendante lle a effectivement 12 ans
de pouvoir
et puis au dossier 1000 2000 3000 4000 a
déposé contre n'atteignant alors vers
qui le président revienne rivlin devrait
se tourner maintenant pour former un
gouvernement
il y a deux prétendants je crois qu'ils
ont déjà été convoqués entre guillemets
par le président rêve ligne dès ce matin
yaïr lapid donc est un ancien allié du
likoud avec son parti il ya deux ans à
peine
je suis et moi liège à ty donc voilà
c'est un ancien allié de netanyahu
et il ya aussi donc naftali bennett avec
un un parti plus à droite a mais
paradoxe ces deux parties le premier
donc yaïr lapid n'a recueilli que 17
sièges le deuxième
yamina 7 sièges seulement donc voyez
vous on est dans une
tuation très difficile et dont les
racines reviennent à la disparition du
parti travailliste israélien a le parti
de golda meyer de de rabin est bien de
thérèse et bien a disparu une ne dispose
plus que de sept sièges alors qu'ils
avaient des dizaines de sièges aux au
temps de sa gloire donc la disparition
du parti travailliste israélien a les
conséquences que nous voyons
actuellement c'est-à-dire l'émiettement
poli est-ce que la solution pour le
président israélien se serait finalement
de se tourner maintenant vers les
centristes c'est à dire hier la piste
que l'on vient d'évoquer avec son parti
à sheffield qui s'est classé deuxième
tout de même des élections législatives
en mars dernier à tout à fait vient de
l'évoquer donc il y a pour ce bloc
une stratégie qui a annoncé le bloc du
changement n'est ce pas eh bien il faut
que ce blog puisse rallier de la droite
à la gauche et à voir donc à un grand
nombre de négociations à mener et au
aussi donc des côtes promis il va y
avoir des compromis très nombreux pour
réunir au moins 60 sièges autour de
partis minoritaires
alors est ce que ces compromis interne à
la politique israélienne vont conduire à
des compromis externe vis-à-vis de la
cisjordanie et des palestiniens
ça c'est une question très intéressant
justement alors si si le président se
tourne vers à yazid il ya irla pidesc il
faut s'attendre à de profonds
changements dans les politiques menées
aujourd'hui par à israël alors qui dit
compromis interne dire finalement
élaboration d'une plateforme commune
minimal plus vous avez de participants à
que ce soit dans une réunion de famille
ou don à une réunion politique à il faut
qu'il y ait à un minimum de poids
d'accord et donc quand vous avez un
minimum de points d'accord et bien vous
n'êtes pas fort de votre maximum et
cette position peut être de faiblesse
du nouveau gouvernement israélien a
conduit plus tard de l'immobilisme
potentiellement car des changements
radicaux
du point de vue extérieur on a tout de
même le sentiment qu israël se retrouve
toujours dans une impasse politique
quasi permanente comment expliquer cette
situation
alors elle pas permanente vient
effectivement d'une situation a depuis
deux ans puisqu'il ya eu quatre scrutins
en deux ans elle n'est pas permanente
puisque sur les 20 premières knesset les
biens les 20 premiers donc session de la
knesset depuis la naissance de l'état
d'israël
la durée moyenne était de 40 mois et
donc depuis deux ans la durée est
descendu à 8 mois seulement
donc la stabilité est très très récente
et on retrouve là effectivement la crise
structurelle de la politique israélienne
qui était historiquement organisé autour
de deux blocs le likoud et puis le parti
travailliste et le parti travailliste a
implosé
merci beaucoup à vous gérard vais faire
je rappelle que vous êtes analyste à
géopolitique chercheur associé à la fée
mots et fondateur du site lemonde
décryptage